Let's take a quick look at how learning switches
work. A learning switch maintains a table between destination
addresses and output ports on the switch, so that
when it receives a frame destined for a particular
place it knows what output port to forward the
frame. Initially the forwarding table is empty, so if
there's no entry in the forwarding table the switch
will simply flood. Let's look at a quick example.
If host A sends a frame destined for
host C, then initially the switch has nothing
in its table to determine where that frame
should be sent, so it will flood the frame
on all of its outgoing ports. On the
other hand, because the frame has a source address
of A, and arrived on input port one,
the switch can now make an association between address
A and port one. In other words, it knows
that the host with address A is attached to
port one. So that in future, when it sees
frames destined for host A, it no longer needs
to flood, but can instead send the frames directly
to port one. So, for example, when C replies
with a frame destined for A, the switch now
has an entry that tells it that it doesn't
need to flood that packet. But instead, can
simply send the packet directly to the output port.
Note also that when C replies, the switch
learns another association between address C and port three.
So future frames destined for host C, no
longer need to be flooded, either. They can simply
be forwarded to output port three. So, in
summary, if a learning switch has no entry in
the forwarding table, it must flood the frame
on all outgoing ports. But otherwise, it can
simply send that frame to the corresponding output
port in the table. Note that learning switches
do not eliminate all forms of flooding. The
learning switch must still flood in cases where
there is no corresponding entry in the forwarding
table. And also, these switches must forward broadcast frames,
such as ARP queries. Now because learning
switches still sometimes need to flood, we still
have to take care when the network topology
has loops. Now most underlying physical topologies have
loops for reasons of redundancy. If any
particular link fails, you'd still like hosts on
the LAN to remain connected. But let's see
what happens when the underlying physical topology has
a loop. Let's suppose a host on the
upper LAN broadcasts a frame. Each learning switch will
hear that frame and broadcast it on all of
its outgoing ports. When that broadcast occurs, the other
learning switches that are in the topology that contains
a loop will hear the rebroadcast. They in turn
will not know that they shouldn't rebroadcast the packet
that they just heard. So each of those switches
will in turn rebroadcast the packet on
their outgoing ports. And, of course, this process
will continue, creating both packet loops and what
are known as broadcast storms. So, cycles in
the underlying physical topology can create the potential
for learning switches to introduce forwarding loops and
broadcast storms. So we need some kind of
solution to ensure that even if the underlying
physical topology has cycles, which it often needs for redundancy,
that the switches themselves don't always flood all packets on all outgoing
ports. In other words, we need some kind of protocol to
create a logical forwarding tree on top of the underlying physical topology.